what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video I will be
starting a new giveaway so if you're
interested in that make sure you stay
until the end of this video to find out
all the details before I get into the
topic I just want to make it clear that
I'm not sure any of this will happen in
season 8 this is more or less something
I personally would love to see happen so
this video is more of a desire than an
actual prediction or a theory but I'm
sure some of this will happen but let me
know if you agree or disagree with me or
you can tell me how you would like to
see things play out during the Great War
but I want to talk about the possibility
of seeing another dance of dragons type
scenario the Great War is inevitable and
as of right now the night king is riding
his own dragon with around 100,000
whites and three giants traveling south
of the wall with him most of you already
know that I believe there will be a huge
war taking place at Winterfell the night
king will have his own dragon and army
and Daenerys will have her two dragons
in army plus Jon and his army for years
fans have always believed that Daenerys
John and Tyrion were all meant to ride
the dragons but now that the night King
has Vasari on the theory of Tyrion
riding a dragon in the television show
is pretty much dead for right now Tyrion
did have a very strong connection with
the Dragons and there is other evidence
to support that he could be a Targaryen
but let's just go with what we all know
is facts
Daenerys only has two dragons right now
and she is currently the one who
controls drogon but we still have ragel
who sure could use a rider right now the
night King took down vissarion with ease
and as long as ragel was flying around
by himself I think he's an easy target
as well when the great war begins I
think someone is gonna need to ride that
dragon and John is a much better
candidate than Tyrion is right now Jon
also has a strong connection with the
Dragons and everyone now knows for a
fact that jon is a legitimate Targaryen
the television show has proven this many
times say what you want about the books
but in the show it is now a fact if they
were ever gonna have Jon ride one of the
dragons then season 8 is the time to do
this not only is it the last season of
the show but Jon will be revealed the
truth about his parentage at some point
during season 8 Jon will learn that he
is a Targaryen
in Daenerys we'll learn about this to
this revelation could give Daenerys and
John the confidence that he too can ride
a dragon and I think they're gonna need
him to ride a dragon in order to win
this war against the knight King John is
already obviously very skilled on the
battlefield but he could do even more
damage in the sky while riding on the
back of Regal Daenerys named regal after
her brother Rhaegar who is John's father
I think when Daenerys and John learn
about the truth of his parents she will
allow John to ride the dragon she
already saw the connection John had with
drogon and I could only imagine John
would have an even stronger connection
with regel if we had John and Daenerys
riding on the Dragons this would set the
stage for one of the most epic battles
in cinematic history we all could
basically see a dance of dragons in the
final game of Thrones season I would
love to see all three dragons in the sky
with their own riders battling it out
while complete chaos is taking place on
the ground between John and Daenerys his
armies and the whites can you imagine
how insane that would look I don't know
if they're gonna do this or not but
personally I'm really hoping that they
do there is only six episodes left and
the budget has increased to 15 million
dollars per episode so why not go out
with a bang and have a war between the
three dragons in the sky like I said I
don't know if they're gonna do this but
I think they will even though that
statement doesn't make much sense I am
still leaning towards Daenerys having to
kill vissarion would drag on in order to
stop the knight King's new dragon since
Daenerys named Roe going after Drogo and
Viserion after Viserys I think Vissarion
will have to be killed by drogon just
like Drogo killed Daenerys his brother
Viserys not only would it be symbolic
but it would also be very emotional
because Daenerys would have to kill one
of her own children even though she
won't want to she's gonna be forced to
but John could also provide some extra
air support if he was riding on Ragle
not only could John take shots at the
night King and Viserion too but John can
make sure no White Walkers are on the
ground chucking Spears at them either
plus he could incinerate hundreds of
White's at a time we all know it would
look amazing if they did this and I have
to believe that they will it doesn't
make much sense having reg all fly by
himself when we all know John as a
Targaryen and he already has a
connection with the Dragons now there
always that possibility that brain could
still do something too I made a video
about brain possibly being able to war
get to Vasari on to regain control the
dragon from the night King which would
be just as incredible but I think John
riding the dragon might be more likely
to happen with only a few episodes left
we need to see a triple threat match
between the dragons and this battle
could even be a setup for the eventual
prequel show that they want to release
if they plan on making a dance a dragon
style show as the prequel then this
could introduce people to how incredible
that could be but these are all just my
opinions and things that would
personally like to see before the series
comes to an end but let me know what you
think down below would you like to see
all three dragons being ridden during
the Great War or do you think John will
eventually ride on ragle or even drug on
if something happened to Daenerys let me
know all your thoughts opinions and
questions down below now let's get onto
the new giveaway that I promised I would
do I had the idea for this giveaway a
while ago but I couldn't decide exactly
how I wanted to do this one at first but
I always liked more people being able to
win something instead of just one person
which is why I broke this down into
seven winners instead of just one what
I'm gonna do is give away the digital
downloads to all seven seasons of Game
of Thrones just like the last giveaway
whoever gets randomly selected first
will get to pick what season they want
and whoever gets randomly selected
second will get to pick whichever season
they want out of the seasons that are
left and so on and so forth the good
thing about this giveaway is I will be
able to give you the download code
immediately instead of waiting for
something to come into mail I will be
able to just take a screenshot of
whatever season you want and send you
the picture of the digital download code
and you can start watching immediately
if you wanted the link to enter the new
giveaway will be down below in the
description and pinned at the top of the
comments if you want to enter good luck
to everybody
and thank you all for watching today's
video I appreciate all the support from
those of you that watch every video and
leave me nice comments and everything
like that I also want to thank my
patreon supporters who contribute to
this channel month after month it truly
does mean a lot to me
I hope everybody has a great day and I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]